welcome to this video playing after dark
what could I play well let's play some
Slav and the flag right I think this is
some Asian flag like Thailand or
something
Thailand yes I got one right okay let's
see a Slav it took me twenty seconds to
put on the board let's speed up here and
play this solid line the selector or
flesh down Slav this is the main opening
of her garter Chomsky's against default
besides the goon fault he's really he
really has perfected this kind of
position for black he's almost never
losing and even winning sometimes which
always strikes me as amazing from this
really not much happening position but
it's working for him perfectly okay so 5
is if I have an idea sometimes it's a
cool technical shot here fine let's do
that it's based on the position of
Knight and Bishop if he takes on d5 with
whatever pawn yeah I take here and I
have 95 next quite often this only leads
to a simplification but it's probably
still the way to go
oh I didn't didn't see that one at all
but what is happening here what the heck
95 okay is the principal news yeah
that's not over thing here it's the if
you want to review it you must play this
not quite sure if you can can refute
that but and this thought night h5f and
it's really it's really just a piece
isn't it I hope it is Queeny to was what
I'm was unsure about maybe I'm
overlooking something here as well as
possible of course but this time
considered to be fine
there's always the issue of this c6 porn
anyway that at the end he will take on
b7 and this policy nuisance but the
problem is a bit where is he going with
the Queen at all I mean find a square
needs to go to some really weird square
g5 maybe h2 looks very depressing
yeah and Queen g5 I probably just can't
take I mean what's the big deal I can
take g5 and maybe even take d3 and c3
this is really lots of pieces off yeah I
probably didn't really appreciate Knight
h5 all right
and that's let's take it it's still it's
still tricky
probably somewhat but think think for a
moment iam just a moment
there is no way to a sacrifice to look I
thought about 93 briefly but this should
be really good I mean I'm threatening 93
I'm just getting another piece and also
be - and don't you deceive his queen is
also cut off it's probably just a win
yeah
rook and Queen being opposite also
something but Bishop c2 is the Yemeni
discovery or Bishop e2 that that doesn't
hang the rook and we should be - it's
not really it's not really flattening at
least I don't see a thread you know but
- how exactly Queen b6 maybe maybe Queen
b6 attacking B to put with this fork
attacking b7
so just take p7 now with watch the Queen
may be the queen so that we should be
three is not coming with the temple
yeah he's still playing without the
Queen on h2
hmm I'm not sure baby should be three or
something a wife I really didn't
appreciate that but I have neither three
oh this is good
Lucas a techno
you know why this white is falling apart
no really rookie when I have rupee eight
probably the most forceful okay what's
the best here Knight f4 maybe neither
form
yeah just briefly think about that
yeah okay come on right there for a
strong I have Bishop c5 coming would be
to coming so night long yeah I just take
it the problem is the queen is it's a
dead piece yeah I can take H 3 and F 2
even maybe wait
hmm I mean I was only wondering about
what the comp suggested here Bishop to
d6 the after sis yeah this is strong he
threatens queen d3 Knight h3 winning the
Queen and white cannot prevent it
yeah lost anyway yeah it's a matter of
of a miscalculation I guess he needs to
go to e2 this is interesting I think I
probably need to take and then something
like this leads to interesting play with
not so much happening you know the
Comicon actually wants to just recapture
yeah I briefly thought about that but
not if I've looked too tempting you just
wants to play this yeah why not actually
this is certainly not a bad position for
black summer ads it's it's quite curious
sometimes in this rather passive
position now that with some technical
means quite often black camera can free
himself and get to get something going
in the center it's very often based on
the fact that simply the fianchetto is a
good position for the bishop yeah
interesting game nevertheless thanks for
watching